la atención en ucrania sigue en este
frente por el control de la provincia
del lugar es la principal batalla está a
mis espaldas donde esa columna de humo
que es la población de vila jurídica y
allí está cercada por un río los cuales
los rusos intentan cruzar han creado
puentes militares provisionales cada
noche los ucranianos no se los destruyen
pero ellos vuelven a construir otro y
según nos hablaban integrantes de las
fuerzas especiales ucranianas esta
mañana han logrado pasar al lado
ucraniano varios tanques y también
tropas así que lo que hacen los
ucranianos es responder con gran
artillería los rusos también responden y
también con ataques aéreos porque su
gran objetivo es cortar esta carretera
que une con otro lugar que ellos ya
tienen en controla el papá y cerrar los
accesos a la población de legis anc y
también otras más atrás que están en con
todavía en control de los ucranianos y
esta sería la primera gran provincia que
podrían controlar los rusos sin embargo
nos decidan los integrantes de las
fuerzas especiales que si bien ellos han
y ha avanzado también los ucranianos
están
todas sus fuerzas aquí para hacernos
retroceder como ya han sucedido por
ejemplo en otras provincias como un
jardín